تبنت مجموعات عرين الاسود
الشهداء الثلاثة توعدت بالثأر
القضية الفلسطينية لا رجعة فيه.
وانه لا يخضع للحملات الانتخابية
الضيقة. وماذا عن التطبيع مع من
يحتل فلسطين ويقتل شعبها? هل هو
لمكان سري لا يعلم مكانه احد حتى
الان. المغرب يؤكد ان موقفه من
جثة الرئيس صدام حسين قرب منزله
وداعش نبش قبره ونقل جثمانه
للاندماج العسكري مع استراليا
لمواجهة الصين. وفي صفقة ثلاثية
عليها في بحر جنوب الصين بانه
يزعزع الاستقرار. واشنطن ترد على
تدخلات خارجية في تايوان. واكد
الرئيس خلال جلسة ختامية لمجلس
تقترب من الحرب العالمية. عندما
تتمنى الموت لعدوك يطيل الله
الامريكية الكورية شرارة اندلاع
حرب جديدة في شرق اسيا? الصين
والسيول العسكرية يمكن اعتبارها
اعلان حرب فيما اعلن الجيش
البحر وقد اعلنت كوريا الشمالية
نجاح الصاروخين في اجتياز
اكبر تدريبات عسكرية مشتركة بين
امريكا وكوريا الجنوبية منذ خمس
ديمتري ميدفيديف تغيير اسم
اوكرانيا الى باشارة الى استبيان
لاستدعاء شبان للخدمة العسكرية
في الحرب. ومن المداهمات الليلية
الوزارة ان قواتها تواصل تنفيذ
عمليات عسكرية في منطقة دونيسك.
الروسية عن مقتل مائتين وعشرين
من الجنود الاوكرانيين في شرق
بعد باخموت. لتأتي الاجابة من
دونيتسك. حيث كشفت وزارة الدفاع
التقدم. ولكن لكل داء الدواء.
فقد استخدم الروس تقنية الجسور
ولا طريق الى مسار السلم في
الوقت الحالي الا باستخدام
الوسائل العسكرية. اليكم المصدر.
واكد الكرملين ايضا انه من غير
الطاولات. نعم الولايات المتحدة
والقيادة الاوكرانية تنتشر فيها
المتطورة في اوكرانيا ومن
التحالفات الى الحرب من خلف
الانتاج الضخم لطائرتها
التدريبية ياسين محلية الصنع.
المقبلين وماذا بعد يا هؤلاء
الاحداث والتطورات. رئيس الوزراء
وتعهد الرئيس الصيني ببناء جيش
قوي يحمي امن البلاد ومصالحها
ساعة صفر. الرئيس الصيني شي جين
بينغ يشدد على ان بلاده اي
الاختبار. بيونج يانج كانت قد
حذرت من ان تحركات واشنطن
تختبر اطلاق صاروخي كروز نوويين
من غواصة قبل ساعات من انطلاق
اجتماع كيم جونغ بكبار ضباط
الجيش الكوري كوريا الشمالية
العسكرية الاوكرانية وهي تداهم
ملهى ليليا بمدينة خاركيب وذلك
تعود لنفس المسمى. وعده لامريكا.
ومن احشاء المحيط صواريخ كوريا
الاوكرانية داهمت ملا ليليا
بمدينة خاركوف لاستدعاء الشبان
الى تبادل الدولية. حيث اقترح
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
الصواريخ الروسية المضادة
للدبابات والدروع على حسم النزال
التي تواجهها في الميدان. اذ اكد
مسؤولون عسكريون روس قدرة انظمة
نعم قاتل الدبابات الروسي يقلب
طاولة الناتو معلنا دخوله حرب
استراتيجية جديدة يستخدمها الجيش
الروسي وقوات فاغمر لتطويق
اعلن انه لا يوجد هناك اي شروط
مسبقة بشأن الوضع في اوكرانيا.
الا باستخدام الوسائل العسكرية.
وبشأن المسائل العسكرية هنا
ثلاثة فلسطينيين جنوبي غربي
نابلس بالضفة الغربية في حين
مليارات جنيه استرليني اضافية في
قطاع الدفاع خلال العامين
العراقي السابق مصطفى الكاظمي
يصد العراقيين ويقول انه شاهد
الوزراء البريطاني ريش سوناك
اعتزام حكومته استثمار خمسة
ستغير الوجود العسكري في منطقة
المحيط الهادئ. لندن وواشنطن
المشتركة والمتعددة ووصف قرار
الصين عسكرة الاراضي المتنازع
التحدي الصيني بخطوة اكثر جرأة.
حيث تسعى الولايات المتحدة
اعلن رئيس مجموعة فاغنر الروسي
يوفجيني بريغوشن عزمه الترشح
في تحريك ورقة غزو مولدوفا ومن
حرب الطاولة لصناديق الاقتراع.
الاف صاروخ. يا لها من صفقة
كاملة الدسم تقع في احضان
الامريكان. ومن تجارة الموت الى
قلب الطاولات. حيث اعلنت الشرطة
الوطنية ولم تكتفي الصين
بالتصريحات والاقوال. وفي خطوة
عمره. ليدخل شي جين بينغ الولاية
الثالثة فهل تصبح حربا عالمية
المتحدة والخاضع لعقوباتها وزيرا
جديدا للدفاع. ومن تحركات بكين
نواب الشعب تمسك بكين بمبدأ
الصين الواحدة على حد تعبيره.
استهدف مواقع وسط وغرب سوريا.
قتل جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اصيب ثلاثة عسكريين جراء قصف
اسرائيلي من اتجاه شمال لبنان
ثالثة? هذا ليس تشابه ارقام بلون
الارقام تتحالف معلنة اقتراب
الكوري الشمالي انه في حالة تأهب
قصوى. فهل تكون التدريبات
موقف لا رجعة فيه ايضا. كشفت
وزارة الدفاع الايرانية خط
تهديدا لها. وفي سياق مخاوف
الغرب من الصين اعلن رئيس
تتعهدان بتقديم خمس غواصات نووية
لكامبيرا وبكين تعتبر المشروع
الولايات المتحدة ستحافظ على
وجود عسكري نشط في بحر جنوب
الصين من خلال الدوريات
الاستراتيجية والتدريبات
الصيني تعيين لي شانج فو المدرج
ضمن قائمة اعداء الولايات
الى الرد الامريكي. اذ صرح متحدث
باسم وزارة الدفاع الامريكية ان
اعتبرت تحدي جديدا للولايات
المتحدة الامريكية اقر مجلس نواب
الاسلحة على مستوى العالم اربعين
في المائة ليطرق الباب اول زبون.
الحرب في اوكرانيا. واشار
التقرير الدولي الى ان الولايات
الصاروخان قطعا نحو الف وخمسمائة
كيلومتر قبل ان يصيبا هدفا في
على زيلانسكي بعد اقتراحه تسمية
روسيا بموسكوفيا والتي يعود
الى اقتحام الملاهي الليلية. حيث
افادت صحيفة بان الشرطة العسكرية
تصرخ نحن هنا ليلوي حاكم بيديه
معلنا شارة الاطلاق. بالتزامن مع
يا لها من خسائر بشرية ليضيق حال
القوات الاوكرانية ذرعا متجهة
اوكرانيا والزعيم الكوري يطلق
صواريخه النووية معلنا تحديه.
وتقتحم الملاهي الليلية. فلماذا
يا ترى ومقترح روسي لتغيير اسم
اسمها الى القرون الوسطى. مشيرا
الى ان اصول الروس واوكرانيا
مؤسس القوميين الاوكرانيين في
الحرب العالمية الثانية وذلك ردا
الفوائد. الحرب تقدم حصة كبيرة
من السلاح العالمي ورائحة الخوف
للخدمة في الجيش على خلفية
الخسائر البشرية الفادحة التي
تتكبدها قوات كييف. اليكم
المصدر. مقطع مصور للشرطة
اوكرانيا على مدى الاربع
والعشرين ساعة الماضية. واضافت
العائمة لمواصلة تقدمهم ليتسائل
الاوكران ما هي المدينة القادمة
باخموت حيث تلجأ اوكرانيا لاسلوب
تفجير الجسور والهدف عرقلة
وكيفية ادارتها وموعد نهاية
الصراع العسكري روسيا. وبشأن
الممكن تحقيق اهداف العملية
الخاصة الروسية في الوقت الحالي
حلف الدبابات الا ان روسيا لا
تعجز عن ايجاد علاج لهذه العقبة
اوكرانيا يا سادة. فمع تسلم
اوكرانيا اول دبابة المانية
حاجة للقذائف. ماذا ان حد ذلك
وحقق بريجوجن طموحاته السياسية
الخلافات تتصاعد خلف الكواليس
السياسية بشأن اهداف الحرب
لمنصب رئيس اوكرانيا للعام الفين
واربعة وعشرين. مشيرا الى انه في
مقاتلو الدبابات الروسي الطاولة
على الناتو ويصد اسلحة الغرب
الصراعات هو الكريملين يسترق
السمع ليدلي بهذا التصريح. حيث
طير.
رئيس جديد يرشح نفسه لانتخابات
اوكرانيا نعم انه طباخ بوتين حيث
حزب الشور الموالي لروسيا في
العاصمة كيشيناو. فهل بدأ بوتين
الاسلحة بنسبة سبعة واربعين في
المائة خلال العام الماضي بسبب
ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث السلام
ان اوروبا عززت وارداتها من
رائحة الخلافات وتتسلل الى انوف
الصحف الامريكية. حيث كشفت صحيفة
بوليتكو نقلا عن مسؤولين في
ادارة الرئيس جو بايدن ان
مع دبابات الناتو في اشارة صريحة
لمنظومة الكورنيت. فهل يقلب
متطورة من طراز يكون حلفاؤها قد
اطلقوا الاشارة الاولى لتشكيل
في مولدوفا انها اعتقلت اربعة
وخمسين شخصا خلال احتجاجات نظمها
كيف ستتعامل موسكو معها. ومن
الانتخابات الى قاتل الدبابات.
هي المستفيد الاكبر من تلك
الواردات. حيث تمثل صادراتها من
تنتشر في الارجاء. والدول العظمى
تهرع بشراهة لشراء الاسلحة خوفا
ولاول مرة يجتمع رؤساء امريكا
وبريطانيا واستراليا وكوريا
حال فوزه بالانتخابات سيكون كل
شيء على ما يرام ولن تكون هناك
قاتلوا الدبابات الروسية يدخل خط
نيران الحرب الاوكرانية الحل في
القضية الفلسطينية وعرين الاسود
تتوعد باخذ الثأر من قوات
الاحتلال. معركة النفس الطويل.
مصائب قوم عند قوم مزيد من
ابرمز وستمائة مدفع هاودزر كي
ناين وثماني عشرة قاذفة وتسعة
دفاعها فانها ستشتري الف دبابة
كي تو ومائتين وخمسين دبابة
ونقصد هنا بولندا الجارة
المحاذية لروسيا. وعلى لسان وزير
اوكرانيا لن يكون سلميا. والقوات
الاوكرانية تترك جبهات القتال
الكاظمي يصدم العراقيين بهذا
السر والمغرب يعلن موقفه من
الجنوبية على طاولة واحدة.
والرئيس الصيني يعلن قد يقود
من صدام ساعة الصفر مع روسيا
وحلفائها. حيث ذكر تقرير معهد
بورقة مولدوفا ويحرك انصاره
لتبدأ الاشتباكات. وتدق اجراس
زينيسكي. هكذا خاطب طباخ بوتين
الرئيس الاوكراني وبوتين يلعب
انا ساكون الرئيس القادم
لاوكرانيا فلتنقل امتعتك يا
لحرب عالمية ثالثة. ورئيس
الوزراء العراقي السابق مصطفى
الخطر في بولندا لتعلن عن صفقة
بتسعة الاف صاروخ والف دبابة.
وحش روسي في سماء اوكرانيا.
لهم.